uh this is grandmaster's choice and i'm
gonna go right from this
into games of game of the week
and i'm gonna go by a match that
recently took place
um in fact it took all these games
happened yesterday the two games i'm
going to go over
they were and they were between the it
was the match between jan napomnishi
and fabiano caruana so
hey ravina how's it going hey i'm jay
tahiri
so basically i'm going to start with the
game between nippon machine karawana uh
this was their first game from their
knockout event this is the ftx crypto
cup
i honestly lose track of all these
things
and it's
you know it's hard to keep track of them
but it's cool that they have these
events all the time
where the formats they play they play at
round robin and then they qualify and
then they play knockouts and stuff like
that
and it's fun to watch again i really
like the candidates and i try to go over
those games but it's fun to go over
these games too and i wanted to switch
it up
so the first one is nippomashi against
caruana where nippo was white it was
their first game
so the game went e45
night after united six so as most of you
know
hey border all the people from my stream
are here
very nice i would say that
uh he's pretty well known for playing
the petrov now
and it's kind of his opening of choice
these days he used it a lot
in the candidates he's used it in the pa
against magnus and he was very
successful in their match
so if you're looking for someone to
model your games after who plays the
petrov
and you want to play it for a win
especially i'd say that fabiano is a
very very good choice
so playing the black pieces here so
nippo takes on e5 and goes back and
takes
so nepal plays d4 which is one of the
big l which is one of the big lines you
can also play knight c3 and for a while
this was quite popular where it takes
and d takes c4
and you try to play bishop e3 or f4
queen d2 and castle queenside
and for a while this was quite popular
these days it doesn't seem to be i'm
wondering if someone
solved the problem there i'm honestly
not sure people can also play with queen
d2
the idea being to pin this knight and
one little trick i'll show you guys is
that a lot of people
will automatically play d5 and lose this
piece because this guy is pinned
whereas of course the correct move is
queen back
and now there's some end game line
involving d3 there's been knight c3 try
but honestly these end games look very
very equal to me something like this
and then queen takes queen and bishop e7
and
life kind of goes on but it's very
difficult to actually find edge in any
of those kind of positions for the most
part at least in my experience
so nepal plays d4 which is one of the
main moves once again welcome everyone
jordo's just joining it's uh
jim young no mushy against fabiano
carawana played yesterday at the ftx
crypto cup which is an online event
i don't know which anon gave me
referring to chess king but i know it's
pretty common so d5
bishop d3 bishop d6 so there are two
uh main branches here uh black can play
with either
b7 or knight c6 on if often they
transpose but for example knight c3
castles bishop v7 is one of the big
lions here
c4 undermining this knight so that's the
whole point that even though black has a
knight here
it often gets undermined so knight goes
to b4 bishop comes back to e2
black usually castles and now white can
play like knight c3 would be the main
move
uh and there's a lot of theory here
there's a lot going on
and it's hard to summarize it all in one
go but i would say it's the less
combative line in a lot of ways so what
fabiano chooses with bishop d6 is the
more aggressive line i'd say for both
sides in some ways
but it's definitely a really really
interesting line
so castles castles
oh man did he really i think i vaguely
remember this
yeah the russian game is the other the
other thing i think that it's the
the english-speaking world that calls it
the petrov i think they call it the
russian in other places but
it doesn't really matter i'm not an
opening name expert by any means
so c4 undermining the knight c6 and this
is the idea you put the bishop on d6
which is a more aggressive square
but rather than developing the b8 knight
you put a pawn on c6
so once again these lines are well known
but it helps to understand what's going
on and the fact is that the bishop is
a little bit better on d6 but because
you're
you're also less developed on the queen
side so there's pluses and minuses to
all of this
and there are many many lines here when
i used to play white
in these positions my favorite line was
actually to take on d5 which looks
counter intuitive
but the idea is you want to play this
and not allow black to take on c4
so here white black's pretty much forced
to take this knight
and then bishop g4 and here there are
all sorts of really cool variations
uh one of the ones i like it goes i
think you play rookie b1
first knight d7 taking this pawn is very
risky
so you typically play here bishop h5 and
then this move rook b5
and i used to love this slime when i was
younger because you get to sack a pawn
it looks weird to play rook b5 but the
idea is that after knight b6
you have this move c4 and the whole
point is that because this bishop on h5
hangs you can't really take on c4 like
you can take here
but it's a little bit on the risky side
because after takes i think after i
think this position is considered pretty
decent for white
because you can play rook takes b7 and
you're very very active on the seventh
rank
and you can't take the bishop back
because your bishop hangs so typically
they play bishop takes f3
kui takes f3 d takes c4 and now you
slide your bishop back here
and you your two bishops provide lots of
compensation
you can try to play for a kingside
attack sometimes you play for a4a5
you have a lot of different ideas in
this position and i find it to be very
interesting
again i'm sure there's a reason why you
don't see this at the higher level
anymore there's usually reasons for
these things
but i remember you know back when i
played this as white which was over 10
years ago
at this point i really enjoyed this line
but in this particular game nippo plays
knight c3 and this also leads to very
very interesting play
so knight takes c3 d takes c4 and bishop
g4
this has been a main line forever for
when i learned this this was considered
a team line like this was considered to
be nothing for white
but i think since then they've found new
ideas
so there are many ways you can play this
nipple plays h3 which is fine bishop h5
and now you can play with rook e1 for
example
knight d7 bishop d3 and just kind of
develop normally
and this is perfectly fine but it's also
kind of tame
and i would say that if you give black
time to develop complete development
get all the guys out i don't really see
white ever having an advantage here
because
structurally white has put more pawns in
the center but they also have more pawn
islands meaning that they have the a2
pawn and the c3 and d4 pawns
and because white's black's pawn
structure is so solid there's no
weaknesses at all
and it's very difficult to push these
pawns like playing c4 d5 is probably
just going to weaken white's position
more than blacks
so i would say that in general these
positions are quite comfortable unless
white can achieve an initiative unless
they can develop some
very concrete form of play so i really
appreciate what nippo does here
because he really kind of takes matters
into his own hands he plays g4 followed
by knight e5
and this is the whole idea is to be
aggressive to try to take advantage of
the fact that i still on b8
and one of his main plans here is to
play with f4 and maybe even f5
and just kind of start storming and it
looks quite risky but the fact is that
black now has to be extremely careful
about how they play
so knight d7 is what most people play
here
but in general i looked into this a
little bit and the lines after this
queen f3 for instance so again if black
does nothing like eventually white's
gonna white's gonna maybe just start
storming on over on this side with
something like this right could be very
nasty
so black usually plays queen f6 and now
simply king g2
and i mentioned this about the pawn
structure but the fact is
white's already grabbed a bishop so the
two bishops here give white
at least something in the end game it
should it be should the end game be
winning for white or anything like this
of course not
but i feel like here it provides a
lasting advantage and at least
something annoying that black has to
deal with uh so fabiano again
and you'll notice this about their games
and it's one of the things i like about
both of these players and one thing
you'll notice
and one of the reasons i really look
forward to an opponent she
carlson match is that they really try to
take the bull by the horns they don't
play like the kind of safe this should
lead to a quality kind of route
which a lot of players do understandably
and there's nothing wrong with that
but they really will try to challenge
and play the most challenging moves a
lot
and a lot of that times that means
taking risks and playing risky moves
so here fabiano does that by playing
bishop takes e5
d takes e5 and then queen a5
and this position i find is actually a
really really interesting one
so nepal played the move queen d4 which
is quite logical
defending the pawn and preventing queen
takes c3 preventing queen c5
but i would have been very interested to
see this move f4
so this is really going all out and
again i don't know how much of this is
prep or how much is
you know them just coming up with it at
the board it's really hard to know i
didn't follow these particular games
live so i'm not exactly sure
but f4 actually i think is quite
interesting
because for example queen c5 check
simply doesn't work because of queen d4
and if you trade to this end game this
is just atrocious with f5 coming in
i don't i want to say almost resignable
like these pawns are just way too strong
so this would be a disaster uh
take c3 looks good because you're
hitting the rook and the pawn
and probably if you've never seen this
position you're thinking well wait
why is why is this not very strong but
wait has a very simple and quite strong
idea here
so i'll give this one to you guys make
sure we got a few people
in the audience coming up with things
so what would you like to do here is
white to be honest it's not
the most difficult question mainly
because there just aren't that many
options
we have a bishop and a rook and a pawn
hanging we have to defend some stuff
right
very good doug so queen b3 and the whole
idea is that if you try to take this
rook believe it or not this is a
position where material really just
never tells the tale because after queen
takes f1
you could take with the king or even the
bishop honestly is fine too
and these pawns are just rolling right
up the board
and there's nothing you can do b7 is
weak
the king is weak f5 is coming
to be honest i actually think bishop
takes may even be stronger
because then there's no b5 with tempo so
you have to either drop b7 or walk into
f5
and this is one of the examples of
the material just not being the most
important factor in the position
here the main factor of the position is
that white's bishops are a monstrous
the pawns are moving up the board b7 is
weak so this position is completely
losing
so after queen b3 i think it's necessary
for black to trade queens
but when you look at this position you
see how enormous
white's play is they're playing ready
for f5 e6 they're ready for bishop a3
and rook out for example
and i feel like this kind of position
black's just really really in some
trouble
so after f4 i actually think the best
option might be the move b5
and i have a feeling that if fabiano
prepared this this is the move he had in
mind and the idea is that if you try to
play bishop e3 now
i can play quite a c3 and there's no
queen b3
so this move is definitely a lot more
annoying in this case
uh i still don't think it's like that
clear like i think the game can still go
on but at least after queen a3
it queen takes c3 it's not so easy so
after bishop v2 bishop e2 might be
a little bit more prudent and once again
we go for this end game but at least
because b5 is in
and the bishop is not on this long
diagonal or this very strong diagonal
i think that black at least have some
chances it's very important of course
they have the move bishop b4 so their
bishop doesn't get trapped
but they play this in knight d7 and i
think the game is still very much
unclear
i probably would take white if i was
pressed just because i still like the
position with the bishops
but at least here it's clear that
black's gonna at least get some counter
play for them
so f4 i think would have been a really
interesting option
for nippo bishop e3 i think
has even been played before is also kind
of interesting where you basically
gambit the e5 pawn
to finish your development and get an
initiative is also very interesting
so he played queen d4 and there's
nothing wrong with this move
and i think that fabiano's response
indicates this was definitely not in his
prep because i really don't like his
response to this move
so if i were black here i would almost
certainly try to get my
knight out to a useful square so he
plays knight a6 which is a developing
move
but the knight also is just really poor
there and i feel like it's just too slow
so i want to get the knight out to d7
but if you play there immediately
you might be able to because c3 hangs
but it looks a little bit too cute like
i think rook d8 is a perfectly
reasonable move
and now the idea is that queen e3 for
example knight d7
and i feel like this is actually a good
amount of counter play for black if
white tries to play f4 here
black has the move knight b6 hitting the
bishop and now bishop to d3
and this move is very annoying because
you can play bishop c4
to cut off the bishop threaten rook d3
and this is kind of a position where i
would not be too happy as white believe
it or not
so e6 is
maybe the best try but after f takes e6
so if queen takes e6 king h8 believe it
or not
the you're actually you have problems
with the c3 pawn and your king
and the queen on e6 looks nice but it's
not doing much so taking with the bishop
i think is stronger
but after king h8 it's just not so easy
you can try like f4 f5 is just very
loose
you could try for c4 bishop b2 but it
all takes a long time
and i feel like if black gets like 95 in
and rook d3
a lot of counter play could be headed
your way very quickly
so i think that this position is just
unclear like i really
don't think that either side is is doing
much better there
border if you mentioned c5 i think it's
still too slow
because i play a move like say queen e3
again and then f4 f5 comes and i think
that
you you haven't achieved enough like
playing knight d7 now
is not going to work because e6 is going
to be a lot stronger because your knight
hangs
and if you play knight c6 i feel like i
can play this move
and unlike the position with the knight
on d7 and the rook on d8 where i have
queen c5 ideas or knight c5 ideas
uh immediate counter play this is not
gonna be so easy
um so i don't think i would recommend
this
in the game he played knight a6
and this was kind of an interesting
moment so i thought before i give you
any
thoughts or analysis or anything like
that i'd ask you guys what you would do
here as white
because i feel like it's i don't know
like it's
it's actually a very tricky moment
so what would you guys do here
it's a way to move because what he
played in the game was fairly strong but
i'm not so sure it was actually the best
but it's definitely like a very like
normal rational move i would say
so board up i actually think it's the
opposite i think if rook d1 i play rook
d
anyway because it's guarded by the queen
right so you actually get skewered there
if you play rook d1
yeah it's okay
yeah bishop g5 is what was played in the
game that's what netbo chose it's a
decent move
but i also feel like it's not it's a
little bit too cute
like the move f4 i think is just direct
and very strong
because now and a couple of you pointed
this out after rook ada queen e3
i don't really see anything too
spectacular because f5 is just coming
right
if you try to play queen c5 i can even
just trade queens
and play f5 and you're just toast so you
probably have to try
b5 first to get this bishop off the
diagonal so now bishop b3 you do have
rook d3 this is an important concept
because now the rook is very very strong
on the third and you still have to be
careful because g6
will maybe drop but queen takes c3 is
also with tempo on the rook i feel like
this is too dangerous
but instead of that white can play the
move bishop e2
and again i i don't really trust black's
position black can play the move bishop
c2 to not lose the bishop
but to me this whole thing looks very
very flimsy
and i feel like it's a matter of just
it's just a matter of time before
something bad happens
a move like an idea like f5 f6 could be
very very very strong
so i i just really don't trust black's
position here i think that this should
be quite good
but at the same time maybe he just
didn't see anything here
so it's quite possible that uh he just
didn't like it for that reason
um he played bishop g5 which is a kind
of a cute move right like you're
basically stopping rook d8 and then
you're gonna play f4 f5
but i do think it gives black a little
bit of time and as we've seen in this
kind of position time is
really of the essence because if you get
an f4 f5 it's just kind of over
so he plays b5
and now the bishop drops back to e2 once
again you don't really want to go to b3
here i don't believe
uh because here i think actually you can
play with c5 c4 so something like this
and then c4 and this is a lot of counter
play because the bishop has to drop back
to d1
which is just a wee bit sad you know
like you don't really want to drop back
to b1 in a position like this
so i think that this is kind of the
issue there so bishop
going back to e2 uh whoops i got yelled
at
bishop going back to e2 is best and now
i'll ask again so what do you
what would you guys do as black here
because i think that this is a very
important position
and i feel like there are a couple of
mistakes for both sides and i'll give
you guys a chance to improve for both of
them so here
um fabiano's move again i think is just
not
working but the reason why
is actually very complicated
um so while i'm waiting for you guys to
come up with a move for black i would
say that
when i go over these games i really try
to follow a pattern which is i look at
it for myself first
and then i check with the computer there
are times i don't even check with a
computer and i just go about
and show present the game with you know
was mistakes like if i go over myself
there's going to be mistakes in my
analysis
uh not that there can't be with a
computer but it's obviously less likely
and i try to figure out what i see with
my own eyes right
and you know how that compares to what
the computer sees and a lot of the times
my own ideas
uh are not as good as the players of
course but in this case this was one
where i wanted to play this move as
black right away
uh what i think is the the best move
here
and obviously that doesn't happen most
of the time fabian is going to play
better moves than me nine times out of
10 or so
but once in a while there will just be a
move that rubs me the wrong way and this
one
was kind of like that for me so i'm
curious what you guys come up with here
because there was a move i wanted to
play so so badly
and i think it's because of how i think
about chess in general
yeah so i'm with bordorf i would have
played knight c7 for sure
i just want to get this knight back in
the game this 996 is just garbage and i
want to improve it and i just hate the
knight there
and the whole idea is that here
knight e6 is the annoyance not so much
knight d5
95 is not a bad move but knight v6
hitting the queen and bishop is actually
quite annoying
because if you try to play f4 here i
think it's just a mistake
because i go here and once i take this
bishop and you have to take my bishop on
g6 is so much more secure
so a position like this would not be
great so after knight c7
maybe black white would just try to move
the queen back or even the bishop back
maybe this is a sneaky move
but even here right like 95 96 are both
possible i feel like black has
time and is getting kind of play
i was kind of with you that f4 was nice
but at the same time queen d4 did
prevent certain counter play that black
could get because black could grab the
c3 pawn in those positions right it
wasn't that simple
uh in the game though fabiano played
rookie eight and this move just rubbed
me the wrong way
uh but what was funny is when i was
calculating it i was like
well i don't really like this move oh
his idea is f4
f6 and i was like ah how clever of him
and that's why nippo in this position
played bishop f3
but this is one of those where i turned
on the computer and i was like what
so i'll give you guys an opportunity
after f4 f6 is his clever idea
and the question is what is the really
really strong idea for
for white now and i'll give you guys a
hint which is that my instinct of the
knight on a6 being bad
turns out to be correct here because
that's actually instrumental
with figuring out this position so think
about that bad night as you try to
consider what you would do
with white here
i don't know gg i would say that
i would say that honestly they do have
plenty of normal games or bad games with
things like this
even the games that i'm going over now
but
like this game between nipponoshi and
karwana
and even the next game i'm gonna go over
where they play with colors reversed
they
like there's a lot of mistakes like many
many mistakes
but that doesn't make it a bad game it's
just two players who are playing a
complex position
and i would argue that there are plenty
of normal games where say the game is
actually just very dry and boring and
they agree to a draw this does happen
and it's not necessarily that they're
boring players it's just
sometimes that's how the way the game
goes even between guys who are very
aggressive
so you can't necessarily say all their
games are masterpieces because
for the most part like they can have
crazy games they can have normal games
and they can have games where they just
blunder uh everything's kind of possible
so you guys are on the ball today a4 is
an amazing move and you have to do it
because if bishop h4
now i plenty play f takes e5 and then
put my knight on e6 and i think that
black's kind of doing the fine again
the 96 is just such a strong defender
the bishop on g6 now is very solid
the bishop on h4 is annoying because it
keeps the rook out of d8 so probably
white's not worse or anything
but i definitely feel like black's doing
fine now
so the key move is this move a4 and this
is just such a nasty move
because the main problem is that now
if you take on e5 i simply take back and
you haven't actually helped yourself
because here
you you still have all these problems
after a4 right so you haven't helped
yourself
if you take on g5 and i take on a b5
you're just going to get slaughtered by
taking on a6 next because everything
hangs
so that's going to be a disaster even f5
is actually kind of a funny move after
that but okay it's obviously not
necessary
and then if you try to play like b4 or b
takes a4 well b takes a4 rook takes a
for you right
if b4 here you actually have the option
of simply
checking and then taking this pawn on f6
so for example uh i don't know i mean i
think
black's just kind of dead but basically
no matter what black does next you can
now take this pawn
and the whole reasoning is that this
this e2 bishop doesn't hang anymore
of course if you try to take the pawn
here your e2 bishop hangs and you don't
really have anything
um yeah so a4 is quite a move
yeah there's actually a funny detail
here like i would play bishop c4 check
almost for sure
but you can actually just take this pawn
because now if rook takes e2
oops
you have to move quincy vortech winning
the rook so if you want to you can
actually just take on f6 as well
so this is just such a nasty move this
a4 move
but it was clearly overlooked by both
players and that's why rookie 8 was
played because he was relying on this f6
trick
um and it worked like nippo didn't see
it but this was this a4 move
when i tell you it's there and i put the
knight on a6 it becomes more findable
but
you guys still did a great job finding
it so quickly but i would say
that it's still
like it's it's still very very
complicated to find in a regular game
where no one's telling you it's there
right
so in the game bishop f3 was played
rook ac8 and now the problem is the
bishop on f3 blocks the f
pawn so things just take a bit longer
and in fact in this position i would
still play bishop g2 with the idea of f4
uh would be my choice he played rook fe1
instead
and now i think fabiano just gets back
in the game
so he plays knight c3
queen b4 to get out of 96 they exchange
queens
96 and we have kind of an interesting
position because
it looks at first like the two bishops
should maybe secure an advantage
but the problem is that black's pieces
are so well placed the bishop on g6 the
knight on e6
c5 is coming all of a sudden all of
black's pieces make perfect sense
and sometimes when you have pieces that
all are very very strong like these
pieces
it means that your position is fine even
if there's some disadvantage that you
might have
i would also argue that because white
didn't get an f4 e5 is a bit of a
weakness
so they both play pretty logical moves
bishop e3 to cover d4 and f4
black plays c5 of course hey azan
b takes c5 knight takes c5
rookie c1 was tried and this move looks
a little funny but he doesn't want
knight d3 coming with tempo
so here i mean knight d3 was still
played but the whole point is that now
he can take on c8 at least
and there's no rook hanging on e1 that's
the whole point
rook takes c8 and here nepal played in
my opinion a very very clever move
he plays the move bishop g2 and once
again i feel like this is a tricky
scenario like what to actually do here
is quite tricky
so what what do you guys think what what
do you think you would do here
because i think this was really like an
important moment uh this is black to
play
white just played bishop g2 so you have
it's black to move
and the question is what would you do
here
these are all interesting moves do keep
in mind though that f4 is a big
problem so for example if you play a5
here and i play f4
you have to have a very good response to
this
right because now f5 is kind of a big
threat
so i would say that this you have to be
very careful with movie a5
and the same problem with a6 a6 also
allows bishop b7 by the way
but i think that f4 would be an even
stronger move probably
so doug mentions rook c2 and i believe
this move is the strongest
but it's the it's for a very concrete
reason it isn't just about putting the
rook on the second
putting the rook on the second is nice
but the main idea is that now if white
plays f4
what move does black have which is quite
strong
so rookie two would feel lucky yeah if
you don't see this move this
is uh quite something but yeah this move
is quite good because now a bishop takes
a7
you play knight takes f4 and maybe
white's not worse after bishop f1 but
definitely i think black's position like
black has nothing to really be
worried about after something like this
right so once you
take that four pawn black has more than
adequate counter play i would say
so uh probably white should instead play
the move bishop d5
and this move is pretty decent but now
black can play your move a5 and i think
that black's just doing fine here
white has the two bishops but black's so
active the pieces are good and notice
how f4 is still not a possible move
so you have to be careful you have to
make sure you don't allow f4 in the
future
but because you have some time because
you've pushed your pawns
i think that this position is going to
be very very promising
so once again i don't think that white
should be worse
or anything like this but i think that
black would be doing just fine here
so after bishop to g2 instead nepo
played the move knight takes e7
and this was i thought a very very
crucial moment
because clearly i think he maybe fabi
just thought that
after knight takes e5 he should draw
easily enough and he wanted to get this
pawn off the board to kill the majority
but i actually think that this is this
is a big mistake in my eyes probably
bigger than
it is in the computer's eyes computer
doesn't like it it likes rook c2 better
but i would say that i would really
really hate to have this position
that fabi got after knight 65 because i
feel like it's very easy for a human
being to lose it
but do keep in mind these guys are
playing rapid games right so they may
not even have time at this point like
this is not really a criticism
of their play right this is more just
how do we learn from this
and i think that taking an e5 too
hastily does allow something
very nice for white so what would you
guys play with white here
yeah f4 is a very very nice move
and the whole point is that if you
take this pawn first you're gonna allow
all sorts of counter play
the move bishop d3 is kind of
interesting here um
for one uh i could also play the move
knight d
oops not there that is not a good move i
could also think about the move knight
d3
and preventing f4 and i think that here
black should have enough counterplay to
draw almost for sure like this position
does not feel like white should be in
any way trying to win
so easily f4 on the other hand
as you mentioned angelos forces knight
c4
because if you don't go to c4 i'm gonna
play f5 there's no rookie two tricks
there's nothing like that anymore so
knight c4 is forced hitting the bishop
and now i take and this is one of those
funny positions because this knight on
c4
looks like a good piece but it actually
doesn't do very much
and it blocks the rook on c8 so i feel
like this is actually
a bit of a problem because black doesn't
really want to play bishop c2 rook c1
bishop a4 or something like that it's a
little bit
too passive the bishop on c on a4 if
bishop d3 you allow rook d1 type moves
and that also is kind of annoying
so fabiano plays f6 which is logical
but now after rook d1 once again it
feels like white's a bit on top
but to actually win this position is not
the easiest thing in the world
so fabiano plays bishop eight he's
basically trying to think about bishop
c6 at some point
so nepo plays bishop d5 check
king f8 and this is a very very clever
sequence by him
so his first move that he starts out
with is bishop back to f2 he's simply
trying to reposition the bishop
it doesn't really do anything on a7
anymore he brings it back home
so flappy plays the move king e7
um i think that he really is aiming to
play bishop c6 but the problem after
bishop c6 here
is that you allow the move bishop e6 and
this looks very very annoying
i should also mention that it's possible
to play bishop c5 check here and this
might even be better come to think of it
because now if king over i play check
you have to go to
d8 i guess but this is already very
flimsy even moves like bishop g8 come to
mind
so i don't think that he wants this so
his idea is to play king e7
and i don't think this threatens bishop
c6 yet
but it does have different ideas and
you're just trying to improve the king
because if
rookie one check you can simply bring
the king up
so i would say that this position is
very very close
to being a draw
not like draw and drawn but i would say
this is a really really
crucial uh position so
white plays the very very clever move
rook d3
and this move is kind of weird because
it
like it it actually prevents rookie one
check as a move but nippo sees that
rookie one is not really going to be the
move he wants anyway
so he plays rook d3 first and here i'd
say fabi
gets a little bit complacent
and the question is how
is this how does this happen uh what
does he pl
like what should he play here
he has to be an f6 who's played you're
liking black's position more and more
but what would you play here as black
that's kind of the crucial point
well the rook just came from rook d from
d1 chess game so he played rook d3
but this is what would black play here
so border suggests knight d6
let's see this move i'm not so sure
about because now rookie three check
becomes kind of a thing
um or even rook a3 like i feel like
you're giving black
white an opportunity to maybe improve so
something like
maybe rook a3 check first because now
the king has to go back somewhere kind
of ugly and then rook a3 is interesting
so now bishop b6 is a thing as well as
rook a7
so this feels like you're giving black a
little bit too much
so i wouldn't really withdraw the knight
from c4 i think that it's doing its job
there at least
h5 is similar to what he played he
played the move h6 which is a perfectly
normal move it just puts the pawn on a
non-hanging square
but actually playing a slow move was
very very problematic
forgot your notation it's funny
so rook d8 it looks nice but the problem
is now it allows bishop check and this
is
definitely very very scary so i think
here
i can just take the knight with check
and that should end the game
so you don't want to play rook d8
yeah it's pretty tough to activate the
rope but i think the key is you have to
defuse the bishops in some way
and yeah angelos bishop f7 is definitely
the best move
because you could trade and play rook
check but this just doesn't quite do
enough
i can drop my king back to maybe g8 so i
avoid bishop c5 check later
um and then if rook b7 i play here and i
don't think you're going to quite have
enough i think most likely the game is
going to liquidate and be
a little bit drawish you do have to be
careful i guess like after here
takes you have to make sure you don't
allow like rook b8 check and bishop c5
and stuff like that but you always have
g6 if you need it you're not really
going to get mated
here so this would not be such a big
deal oops
so bishop f7 so probably white would
draw the bishop
somewhere like this right
and now you have a move like knight b2
activating the knight and this is quite
annoying
because the whole idea now is that the
rook is ready to come into either c1 or
c2 and wreak havoc
if the move rook a3 for instance you can
play b4 even
rook a7 check king f8 and the rook's
coming in
to c1 c2 and black's getting all sorts
of counterplay here and once black's
pieces get active i think it's going to
be
very difficult for black to white to
really show anything with the bishops
the bishops still look good
but rook c2 and knight d3 is going to be
massive massive
counter play
um as far as bishop c6 goes
then i think that you're you're running
into bishop c5 check issues again so
bishop c5 check and bishop e6 or
something could be very bad
um something like this i believe
so after rook d3 fobby played h6 but the
question is how do you punish this move
it looks like black can afford a slow
move if white's just playing rook d3
but there was a very very sneaky idea
with rook d3 and that's kind of what i
would like you guys to find
so what is the sneaky idea
a4 wow all right i have to i have to
bite like what's the idea after i take
you have to have something right
so rook c3 is your plan okay
but here i'm a little bit confused what
happens if i play bishop f7 here
feels like now you have to try to make a
draw on that opposite bishop end game
yeah g4 at some point but g5 the problem
is it's going to liquidate lots of pawns
right so you have to really time it
correctly if you want to ever want it to
do anything
but someone did mention the correct move
which is bishop e1
and i think the key is that it's hard to
realize this is the threat and how big
of a deal it is
but the fact is the bishop coming to b4
with check is
massively problematic because it just
kills any squares the black king has
and it makes it so that like you're
basically just coming in with all your
pieces and it's going to be really
really nasty
now it's important to note that the
reason why rook d3 threatened this
oops sorry is that uh after king e7
sorry if you try to play bishop e1
immediately
what's the problem because at first it
looks like this move should do the trick
but black has a resource here
correct knight e3 and at first this
looks suicidal because of bishop check
but even if we go king e6 there's
nothing really white can do
because you're you're still forked so
any
discovery with the bishop so for example
this move runs into knight takes d1 and
you actually just lose a piece
so you're kind of stuck as far as great
moves here i believe
so you have to play something like rook
d3 and i take this bishop and this
should be quite drawish
um i think the easiest is just king e6
with the idea of rook d6 king back
and i don't think that you should ever
lose this position really
so yeah so rook d3 was so clever because
it it's threatening bishop e1 but it
looks like it doesn't have a threat it
looks like rook d3 is just a move
and that's why fabiano who obviously is
quite strong
just played h6 because he thought rook
d3 didn't do anything so this idea of
nippo's was very clever
but after h6 bishop v1 believe it or not
i think black's already very close to
lost because the bishop coming to b4 is
that strong
fabiano tries bishop c6 now but after
bishop b4
check king e8 now white has to move
bishop e6 and this is remarkably strong
because he plays rook a8 he can't go to
d8 of course why not
nepo seems to be a decent player well
put
yeah there's a reason why he's
challenging for the world championship
right
bishop f7 check very good the idea being
takes takes
so we can't go to d8 so we played the a8
and now
white simply takes time out to play a3
and this is where it becomes obvious
that
something has gone horribly horribly
wrong because
the bishops just completely control
black's king they completely dominate
the position
and really it's just a matter of getting
the rook in the game
so this position is already i would say
pretty much lost
uh for black and it happened in the
blink of an eye
um and here fabiano played rook a7
but what's interesting is that okay both
players probably didn't have tons of
time although nepal plays very fast
but i would say one of the things that
nippo does if he has uh a weakness
and of course even the very strongest
players have weaknesses right
compared to any of my weaknesses they'd
be minuscule right like
um but they all have them and one of the
things i would say with nippo is that
sometimes he can be a little bit
complacent when he has a winning
position
is something i've noticed meaning that
he has a position he's
played beautifully he has these bishops
and he's like he kind of
he makes a mistake which a lot of chess
players make which is you kind of assume
the position is going to win
itself ah i got the two bishops they're
just going to destroy my opponent
um so let me win themselves so he played
the move king f2 which is a nice
building move and i think you'd play on
autopilot
and it's definitely not a bad move
however in this position
he could actually just immediately do
huge damage
i mean it wasn't really his plan um mj
the uh like it was definitely not his
plan to play
knight e5 to c4 it was more that a
concrete thing he missed he thought that
after like knight takes e5 it would be
like a little bit simpler
and i think he missed the trick that
after rook c2 f4 rookie 2 is always
there
so with these guys it's usually not
something too
super basic they're missing sometimes it
is but a lot of the times it's something
slightly deeper
uh and also keep in mind that when
you're actually playing the game it's
much harder to see all this
i think people underestimate that h4 is
tempting all these moves are tempting
but i'm not quite seeing ah
i'm not quite seeing the right move just
yet but i think you guys will get there
honestly king f2 is a nice move right
there's nothing wrong with king f2 by
itself right
it's more that it does give black a
little bit of a reprieve
uh for the time being
right like it at least gives black a
little bit of time to repair
and honestly it's hard to repair this
position completely
rook c3 maybe but you have to keep in
mind you're not necessarily even wanting
to take this knife
because like you look at this position
right like you do something like this
let's say i play bishop d7 for instance
and you take this knight
you've won a pawn but you've also ended
up in an opposite bishop position
where it's not entirely clear what your
winning plan is now if i put my king on
f7
like how are you going to actually win
the position your pawn on a3 is not
going anywhere
so i would actually argue that if you
take on c4 you've actually given away
some of your advantage you haven't
increased it
i think at least in my view the bishop
on the two bishops are much stronger
than that pawn up position
because then i don't have seven by
itself just doesn't do that much
yeah so there is a trick here bishop f5
so threatening bishop g6
which is needless to say a remarkably
strong threat it's practically made if
not for rook f7
so black has to play king f7 and now
once again you threaten me one of the
things i always try to tell my students
is that if you can threaten matan one
you should look at the move it doesn't
mean you're going to play it especially
in an end game you're trying to win
right he didn't want to allow the king
up almost for sure but the fact is that
black just does not have a good move
here
because now you're threatening mate and
what would you like to play here
like how does black defend against the
mate threat because you have two ways to
do it but neither one
is all that great
so g6 is one but the drawback with g6 i
believe
is that i can play rook ffa check and
then bishop e6
and this is highly problematic because
now i can play rook g8 check swing the
rook back somewhere else perhaps
so this position is actually hugely
problematic
like you're probably just going to lose
very very soon
um i don't know how else to put it
so that's not gonna really work
there are some really funny lines you
can do here as well because
for example like i'm just gonna play a
move for black because there aren't that
many great ones honestly
but let's say black uh i don't know
plays like rook c7 or something right
some move like this one of the cool
tricks you can do is you can actually
play with
g5 and believe it or not here you're
probably already mating
because after um pawn takes pawn for
example
pawn takes pawn pawn takes pawn i can
play check
and you have two options here you can
play king h6 but then i play
check if you go here this is going to be
mate
power of two bishops right and if here
i'm going to play this
and mate you this way or the other
alternative
is after rook check instead of key h6
you play here and now i simply go here
threatening rook h8 i guess you do have
this move
to be fair i completely miss this but it
would not surprise me if black has some
kind of mating idea here like i'd be
very surprised if black survives this
position
something like rook check for example
and then rook here i guess bishop d7 i
probably got careless honestly with this
this was
a little bit too cute but this is just
an example of one of the ideas white can
play keep in mind white's not in a rush
black has almost no moves here right
so rook 8 the problem with the rook 8 is
it allows rick f7 check
and then i could take on f6 at the very
least so this is also not going to work
oh king f6 is also a move yeah doug
makes a good point you're supposed to
check on g8 g8 first before you do this
of course
um but it was just more to show like
some of the mating patterns you can do
like more likely after rook c7
you're probably just gonna check with
the rook and move your rook somewhere so
for example rook d8
i think would be more likely and now g5
is maybe in the air
um bishop c3 by itself is going to be
very strong
so this is also probably better i got
carried away
right i just wanted to show like some of
the mating patterns that are possible
but obviously i went way too overboard
but that's okay
so bishop e8's the other move to try to
defend but needless to say this move is
also not great
and i think white can actually just play
h4h5 now
and it's just very sad probably black
has to play g6 but then you can win a
pawn like this and
this is upon up position
i don't know i feel like it's not just a
pawn up like you're just gonna
probably lose very soon um
like you can take on a3 but i something
horrible is going to happen to you here
like that's usually the way these things
work i don't actually see it right away
though
interesting
yeah i think you can still play for me
maybe something like here
so the rook would have to move and now
yeah these are the kind of positions
where your king just doesn't live like
something just happens to your king and
there's nothing you can do about it
but once again i don't actually see the
mate so
i was thinking rookie seven but then
there's this move i guess
and at the very least you don't win
immediately like you have to work for it
because h5 king f6 you're not quite
checkmating yet
yeah okay maybe it still takes a bit of
time
um not so simple yeah
you have a few different options
honestly like i'd have to look at this a
little bit further maybe some
something like this actually works you
can also play bishop back to e4 by the
way
but in general this is going to be a
very very difficult defense for black
um in the game he played just king f2
bishop d7 and here
bishop g8 which i think is a really nice
move he's basically just
surrounding the king making sure he
keeps the two bishops advantage
uh and here fabiano probably should have
tried g5
um just to prevent these pawns from
coming up and after f5 rook a6
and at least here with knight e5 the
rook covering f6
i feel like there are at least some
chances to draw
in the game he played f5 and this really
really should not work
after g5 hg fg g6 was played
and here there are different options
kind of um
but once again i think that nipple plays
a slightly more careless move
and in this case like during the like
when i analyzed it myself like again i
wanted to play a different move
but i was surprised by how big the
difference actually is
because believe it or not like it looks
crushing for white at least to my eyes
but
black actually has some resources here
so playing precisely
is actually a very very important thing
to do
and once again i have a feeling it was a
position where he didn't feel like he
had to do this
and i think that's what ended up you
know making it so that he didn't do this
but
he absolutely should have done this
so what is the best continuation for
white hair do you guys think
so rook d6 hangs the rook to knight
takes d6 you have to be a little bit
careful
yeah so chess king has the right idea
you play h4 and the right idea is
actually very very cool
so you play g6 uh sorry you play bishop
c6
and here you play h5
takes and g6 but what's really sweet
about this
is what is your actual threat here say i
play the move rook g7 this is the really
cool part for my
for me what is your actual threat here
so yeah bishop f7 which is looks like a
good move but i take
and now what
bishop h7 may actually work just because
the
bishop c3 check three senate is good but
you have something better here
black definitely has pawns
yes i think you see it now
yes
and now you just get a queen
so that's kind of a nice a nice little
trick
um because
if you if you end up just taking back
and i take back you're not really
doing a whole lot here this is actually
very likely a drawn position i would say
it's two pawns for the exchange right
but rook d8 just is
absolutely crushing so very very cool
and there's no way to stop this threat
that's why it's so strong
so nepa plays king g3 which again it
looks like just a normal move
everything's nice
blah blah blah
but the question now is
so fabiano plays rook a6 and then he
kind of loses pretty
quickly but it turns out he could have
played the move bishop c6
and now let's say white goes about this
idea again you play bishop e4
the rook comes to d7 next and believe it
or not i actually think black's totally
back in the game
uh white's still better almost for sure
but this is a game now
and notice how it's because of one slow
move king instead of king f2 he could
have maybe
done something really strong by force
instead of king g3 he could have played
h4 h5
so it's kind of like some players i
think are the opposite some players like
fabi for example if he were white he
would almost certainly try to make h4h5
work that's kind of his style
is to be very concrete and sometimes
when you're playing technique
you can go overboard with that kind of
stuff and
i think that like it's important to be
simple when you're trying to win a
position if you can
but there are also positions where you
really should play quickly and i think
this is one because now
black's kind of getting untangled
black's getting his pieces out black's
activating
and i think that when your opponent is
passive sometimes you have to strike
before they can become active
and yes exactly you have to see this
whole line when you play h4h5 it's not
that it's that simple right
but i think that someone like nippo
sometimes veers the other direction
he'll try to be very very simple
but the problem is sometimes simple is
just not as effective especially if your
opponent cannot tangle
so very very interesting and i don't
mean to generalize about the players of
course
they can both make mistakes in both
directions right but i would definitely
say that king f2 and king g3 are both
very natural moves which turn out to be
slight errors
but after rook a6 h4 i think that
black's just kind of hosed
rook here and then one last final point
which is really funny is he can play
bishop h7 safely
um he probably should play bishop f7 but
now after h5
takes you take here and this is just
very very good for white bishop d7 check
is a monstrous threat here
and the g pawn is very strong so this
would have been very good
he played king f7 and now rook d8 was
tried
and this is just absolutely crushing
because if you try something like king
g7 check
king g7 now you actually do get mated
with this you can't take the bishop
because of rook h8
and after this you get mated this way
so a very very cool checkmate uh in the
game he played rook takes a3 check which
is probably the best try
but this position was just not that not
that difficult rook d6 is a nice move
the idea being he takes g6
and this is just too much rook behind
the pawn
he trades off the bishops i'm fast
forwarding a little bit but basically
the rook just kills the knight here
because you basically just don't allow
blacks in with the king and then your
pawns just win because if f2 king g2
you're not really doing much here so
this would have been all she wrote so
after g6
um fabi resent
so quite an interesting game the next
two games after this
were draws and
so then the fourth game in order for
fabiano to save the match
he had to win with this final game with
the white pieces
and that's what we're gonna look at now
so this is the final game of the the
first day
the second day by the way today they
also died two two and i think
uh nepal won and tiebreaks i want to say
is that what happened
anyways i didn't follow as closely
because i was working most of the day
but that's kind of how it works
all right so
e4 e6
d4 d5 so this is their second game i'm
going right into
my uh game of the week lecture which is
this game
so e4 e6 d4 d5 this is game two
game four so we have another
we have this advanced french which they
played quite a bit of actually
knight c6 knight f3 and here there's a
kind of a branch
so um the main line for quite a while
and it's still one of the main lines is
queen b6
this is probably the most common move
and the idea now is if bishop d3 you
play bishop d7
and you can of course go for this but it
is a pawn sack right i can now grab
this pawn and there's a whole bunch of
theory here after like knight c3 i think
is the man move
and life kind of goes on but this is
like a very very sharp pawn sack
um if you play you could play bishop e2
here
and then the idea is i play cd
followed by knight e7 and the knight
comes to f5
or you can play a3
and here i play c4 knight bd2
knight a5 and this is kind of the main
line but one of the things i would say
is that this queen on b6 now doesn't
make that much sense
it's just not the most logical piece
because the queen kind of wants to be
back on c7 or something here
so given this one of the clever ideas
for black is to play this bishop d7 move
so in the game fabiano plays bishop ii
but one of the kind of clever ideas with
this move if bishop d3 you can still
play takes in queen b6 or
or something along these lines is still
quite playable
and the whole idea is that if you play
with
a3 here and i play so f6 is also a move
here which is quite interesting
uh because the queen's still on d8 it's
a little bit more playable but here you
can also play this
then a5 and the whole point is that now
black's queen can go to c7
where it's a lot more logical in these
positions then on b6
so just kind of a little bit of a tidbit
for you guys
um however after bishop d7
fabiano plays bishop b2 and this is one
of the lines where
you can see why if the queen were on b6
this knight coming to
f5 would carry more sting with it
because it would already make big
threats
whereas here it doesn't so it's kind of
like a subtle little thing
but okay not a3
i know there's a never playoff six thing
but honestly if you're gonna play the
french you gotta be willing to play f6
and we'll get to that so cd cd and this
position nipple plays a very interesting
idea which
is f6 so the main line here goes knight
f5
knight c2 queen b6 and you kind of
transpose to these other lines a little
bit
castles and then either bishop b7 or any
number of moves right like this is a
very common position this is kind of the
normal way to play and i think that they
played similarly to this in a
game that happened later but in this
game
nepo plays f6 i should also point out
that
for the set right for this you know this
match this game is basically a must-win
game for
fabiano so and i want to point this out
because
nepo who only has to draw to save the
match is not playing berlin he's not
playing one of the most solid lines he's
playing the french and he's playing it
this sharply
so i feel like this is something to kind
of note about nippo that even if he's in
a
must-draw game or whatever he can still
play very very aggressively
but f6 is actually quite a logical move
here because you're trying to undermine
the center
and you're trying to do it very quickly
so this f6 move is quite where
in my database it had only been played
once uh and it had been played believe
it or not by
simon agdistin the norwegian player
and former coach of magnus carlsen
against none other than magnus himself
and magnus here
played the move castles which is kind of
the move i would veer towards
i don't like developing my opponent's
guys so i much prefer this move
and the drawback to it is that you can
get a slightly weak e5 pawn
so this happened in the magnus game
knight c6 but here he played the move
very exciting move knight b5
and i think that this is actually quite
promising for white
eight six was played in here knight d6
check is actually quite interesting
because i don't think it's so easy to
win that pawn back
there are other moves as well but magnus
played the even more interesting bishop
d3
the idea being queen h5 check because
here if you try to go for this
you're actually just getting mated let
me do it the fun way i'll take with the
queen
because we can and this is checkmate
so just as a fun little line
um so of course agnes stein played g6
instead and ended up winning the game
but i do feel like magnus had a very
promising position
uh he played queen g4 here knight takes
e5 queen g3 and
the game just was quite insane but
definitely white had a very promising
game so i kind of would have preferred
this honestly to what fabiano did as
white
but what he did is also quite
interesting he plays takes on f6
and the reason i don't like this is
because after gtx f6 now bishop g7 is a
thing and trying to castle
so again i'm not saying objectively
castles is so much better it's more like
my preference would be to play castles
um yeah fabio that's a good point like
i i don't i don't love taking on f6 but
it's also
still very very much possible the one
thing i would say though is that i
definitely don't like our knight on a3
so i might have taken the moment here to
play knight eighth knight b5 which looks
like a threatening move
and the idea is yes you're stopping
bishop g7 because bishop g7 runs into
check and takes this pawn and knight c5
and this is the disaster of course
so you have to defend against it by
either moving the knight or maybe queen
b8 is actually the most
prudent and here i like to castle and
the idea is that
your knight can just drop back to c3
when it wants to now
but okay black still plays bishop g7 and
has a decent game i just
really don't want my net on a3 so my
temptation
is to play knight b5 um in the game he
simply castled
bishop g7 and now knight c2 and this was
a really interesting moment because i
think nepo castled i'm sure very quickly
and i think most players would but i
actually think that he could
if he stopped to think here he might
have thought about playing a move like
a5
which looks like a very strange move but
the main idea is that this
b4 idea that white gets in the game is
extremely annoying
and sometimes even when you're ready to
castle
and it looks like castling is what you
should do there are times when an idea
is so annoying you should actually put a
stop to it before you castle
and this is one of those times like i
really think that a5 is a very
interesting move i would definitely
consider it at the very least
um and i'm not saying it's that clear
but i definitely think i would strongly
consider it because after castles
fabiano plays b4 and this pawn push is
just so annoying
because now if you ever play e5 you have
to worry about this pawn coming to b5
and the pawn on b5 just makes black's
life kind of miserable
but this is a very very interesting
moment so he plays a6 which is also a
move i'm unsure about because i i don't
think that a6 a4 helps
black in any way really i think that
probably leaving the pawns was a bit
wiser
um but it's very complicated so we're
going to actually move past
it for the moment but the key is what to
do after e5
because this was a moment where
fabiano's move
surprised me greatly but i was less
surprised when i tried to calculate this
position and i realized how
very complicated it was
um so i don't exactly know what i would
do here but i'm curious what you guys
would do
what i know is that fabiano's move is
probably not best it's a little bit
i don't know
it's not really in the spirit of the
position i don't think
so what would you guys do here is white
because to me this is a very very
difficult position to play
yeah knight e3 is interesting uh the
drawback is it does drop b4
so i might be able to take that pawn but
i also might just play e4 and f5 and
this these pawns rolling up the board
would make me very very nervous with the
knight on e3 i would say
so i don't know if 93 is what i would
choose
yeah playing b5 is not so bad if they
take on b5
a takes b5 knight is a one you're
actually not that unhappy with that
development i don't think
um or i i think actually you can even
take on c6 or think about it
no trying to think actually takes
yeah i think this this line in general
yeah takes on c6 takes on
c1 so you take back but yeah this i
think is definitely not bad for white
uh definitely kind of decent uh in the i
was looking at the move knight a5 but
even this is actually
not so easy um
but i think you could play this way and
then maybe just rook b1 to stop knight
b3
e4 and knight h4 and the idea is you can
maybe play f4 at some point or
you know g3 and try to control that four
square
so that's kind of the question um
and it's interesting because what the
computer likes is something which didn't
occur to me right away
but actually is very logical when you
look at it and it's one of those where
i think at least one of these guys for
me to come up with it would be more
difficult
but i think one of these guys could kind
of do it and it's actually to take so
taking looks very counter-intuitive
because you give black these pawns
but the fact is you at least don't have
this horrible weakness on d4
and i would say that black at least has
something to prove now because black
king's more open and stuff like that
but the key is you have this move rook
a3
and this move is very very logical
because you're trying to bring the rook
over to the queen side to the king side
to be able to attack
so e4 looks scary and playing knight d4
i think has some risks to it
but you can actually play knight g5 and
the thing is because the d5 pawn always
hangs the e7 knight can't move
and that makes life very annoying so
black should probably get rid of this
knight
but even if you go to h3 knight f4 is
possible rook g3 is sometimes in the air
and i would say that this position is
actually quite promising for white
because these pawns look very nice but
they're also not going anywhere
so i don't know it's one of those where
it's very very difficult to evaluate
this kind of thing
but i would say that probably black is
actually has to be very very careful
here
um because once again like you have to
really watch out for
like rook g3 bishop h6 ideas and stuff
like that like you could end up losing
very very badly here
um if you're not careful so at the same
time
i definitely this was not intuitive for
me at all i wanted to play b5 as well
um and i don't think it was for fabiano
so he ended up choosing bishop a3
so he's trying to play b5 in a more
clever way but i think that this is just
too dangerous because
nipple plays e4 and then f5 and this
looks very scary to me
uh but one of the things i've noticed
with fabiano's play is that he's very
brave like he doesn't get scared by puns
shoving up the board at him
like it just doesn't bother him very
much and
a lot of players like myself would be
just utterly terrified here
i agree angelos like i i had a very very
difficult time with d6 e5
but at the same time it makes sense in
that
the pawns don't really go anywhere too
quickly and
the pawn on d4 now is just kind of a
weakness that you have to deal with all
the time
uh and i definitely like the idea of
getting the rook out because right now
the bishop and rook are just not really
playing and black's king is very
very safe whereas our own king might not
be safe for very long
so here in knight b3 and this was a
position where i think
nippo played a move which i'm not as
crazy about so i'm kind of curious what
you guys
would do here
yeah but i would say guys like the one
thing i would say about the dtx5 line
and i'm not saying i would have played
it myself necessarily but i think that
when you realize that your deep four
pawn is such a horrible weakness and
that now
f4 f5 f4 is coming the pawn on e5 and
the pawns on e5 and d5 don't look nearly
as scary
because these pawns coming up the board
here look really really nasty
b5 is quite an interesting move actually
i didn't i have to admit i did not
consider this
um yeah and i'm not exactly sure what
happens now maybe white just plays
knight c5
but this is definitely an interesting
idea b5
i don't know if you meant it for black
or for white but
yeah i'm with you guys i think f4 is
quite a strong move
and i think he was worried about the
move b5 and i think this is what
fabiano was banking on but i think black
can actually just put the knight
back on a7 and it's not so easy to
actually take advantage of this
uh and in the meantime f3 is gonna be
like
bone crunching type of threat um
so i think white has to be very very
active and play knight c5
but here you can even just drop back to
c8
and the idea is that if you try to play
bishop g4 i can play that f5
and everything kind of glues together
and these e4 and f4 pawns are still
there and are going to be very very very
strong
once again f3 is going to always be in
the air the queen's going to come out to
g5
it's definitely not clear that a7 does
look kind of silly
but at the same time i think that takes
and b6 can come later forcing the knight
away
the b5 pawn might be weak and once the
knight leaves
like black can play rook f6 to g6 for
example there are just so many promising
ideas here
that at the very least i would be very
very nervous
in the game he played the move knight g6
which seems very
rational but i think that
it's a bit inaccurate so here
i don't know um
i think that this was actually an
important moment for me
yes so
fabiano played the move f4
and i don't mind the idea i think the
idea is correct
but i would almost certainly played b5
first
uh because now after knight ce7 you take
and play
f4 this looks very very annoying because
bishop takes a4 bishop takes e7 wins a
piece
so you don't have to worry about that
and now knight c5 comes next
and i feel like this is kind of a better
version of events he plays the move f4
himself first but the problem now is you
give black an
extra opportunity to do something on the
queen side
um so
let's see uh yeah knight g6 does not
stop b5 his idea is that he didn't want
to put the knight on a7 right
so he plays knight ce7 that's the whole
idea knight g6 was to
give the e7 score to his knight so he
didn't have to win that a7
which is quite logical but in this
position fabiano played a move which
dumbfounded me
like i don't think i would consider this
move in a thousand lifetimes
and it was quite surprising
if you mean b5 f3 farther back like of
quite a few moves back
i think that it like f f3 i can probably
take it and you don't have immediate
mate or anything like that
but it's definitely something to
consider
and by the way i'm not asking what did
fabiano play because i don't think it's
a very good move i'm asking what would
you play heroes white
g4 would definitely be surprising
and what's funny is his move is kind of
bad for concrete reasons in addition to
kind of positional reasons but the
positional reasons is why
i would not play it yeah i mean knight
c5 is what i would choose as well
probably right like just get your knight
in the game
uh knight takes b7 is a thing b5 is a
thing and i think that
fabiano by all counts is totally in the
game
um i don't think that anything terrible
has happened to him
however instead he played the move a5
and this move i just don't
like b5 i would understand i don't know
if it's good
but i would understand b5 you're opening
up the bishop you're getting your pieces
in
a5 i understand he's kind of securing
the c5 square for his knight but
like to do this to your a3 bishop
is really really sad uh but napo's
response i think would be what fabi
maybe missed because
i i'm assuming he his plan was to do
this play knight c5 and play b5 or
something and then
even though this looks a little silly it
maybe would justify itself at some point
again i have real doubts about this
honestly doug i feel like a5 might be a
miss clicker it's so hard for me to
imagine him playing this move
but at the same time nippo's response is
very precise and very strong
so see if you can find it black to play
here and what is a very precise and
strong move
bishop a4 very very good and the main
problem is he'd love to play knight c5
but now you can simply take and take
this pawn with check and this is going
to be very bad
so i think that he was banking on knight
c5 here and then he realized it doesn't
work
so instead he played the move knight e3
but this is a very sad move because now
he's basically pitting himself
and here i think that black has an
exceptionally strong move so nepal
played queen c7 which is not like a
terrible move i guess
but it's definitely not my move of
choice
i think that black has an incredibly
strong move here
and what i like about this move is that
it's extremely positional
as well as tactical
and the main thing is ask yourself what
what black what white wants to do here
so bishop takes d4 is an example
of a move which i would really hate to
play because now after queen takes d4
and bishop a
b2 all of a sudden i'm in business i'm
threatening queen g7 check which you can
defend i guess you can play rook f7
but look at my bishop and queen look at
all my ideas i can try to play h4h5 here
like
i feel like this is a way to like try to
lose almost
it sounds drastic but i feel like this
is a way you can easily just lose
if you're black so i would definitely
not want to take the d4 pawn
knight c6 is is a logical move but now i
can play b5
and then i'm not even just trying to
grab an exchange i'm trying to free my
bishop
and i feel like this is also something
you don't want
so his move uh kind of prevents that
so once again if you give white a free
move they'll almost certainly play the
move b5
or some move along those lines
and i think that that's gonna be pretty
annoying maybe even
like rook c8 maybe you have to play
bishop e2 but
um but it they can't play it yet right
like in this line with bishop d4
you have to play you have to play rook
f7 first right
and here i guess if h4 there's knight c6
that's a great point
but maybe i can play b5 first for
example
the main issue here is that you you've
allowed my bishop and rook to become
like
bishop and to become very strong and i
just don't think this is something you
should even consider
doing because you have such a huge
positional advantage here
that i would never ever think of giving
out my positional advantage for that d4
pawn like it just would never ever occur
to me because
my positional advantage is so great that
i don't want to
grab a pawn like that like ever and make
my opponents bishop
like look at this you're turning this a3
bishop from the worst piece on the board
to like the best piece it's just not
something you'd want to do
so even even like the biggest pawn
grabbers in the world
uh wouldn't really want to take that
pawn
yeah i'd probably take white as well uh
in that line
so b5 uh very good is extremely strong
here
and the main idea is that
you're basically crushing this bishop
and you're also stabilizing the bishop
on a4
so sure white could play a move like
this
but now if you can just take and grab
this pawn
and this pawn is a very easy one to grab
because you're not really giving up
anything to grab it
so b5 i think is just an incredibly
strong move because you're killing every
b5 idea white has
and if instead oops if instead white
plays a takes b6 quee takes b6 now you
have two weak pawns
and the queen on b6 is remarkably strong
so b5 is an excellent move in my opinion
in the game he played queen c7 keep in
mind knight 6 f4 rook takes up 4 was a
thing
but now he's maybe threatening it so
fabiano plays rook c1
and then queen d6 so nepo's idea i would
call clever because
you're basically saying well now your a3
bishop hangs so you can't play a b5
but this doesn't feel as clear to me now
white plays g3
rook ac8 and here fabi finds a very very
good move
and it's a typical move like not so
difficult to find i feel but it's
uh definitely by far the best that keeps
him in the game because again white's
the one in trouble here not black so
white has to stay in the game
when you have a weakness like this pawn
on d4
and remember this position by the way
because d takes e5 to all of us seems
like oh man how could white play djc5
but when you realize how weak this d4
pawn is and how this whole thing came
about
at some point you're going ah maybe d65
is not so bad right
especially if black could have gotten an
f5 f4 yeah
yeah i mean knight c8 to d6 in that
position would have been maybe
very tempting i agree but okay this
position white to move what would you
guys think about
remember you're trying to stay in the
game right you're you're in trouble
but you need to stay in the game you got
to keep tension you got to give yourself
ideas you got to get your pieces into
the game
so how would you go about it
rook c5 very good because again you got
to keep
tension and the idea of this move is
you're now threatening b5 b5 is now a
very very strong threat
and you're basically your whole goal is
to open up your a3 bishop
so after rook takes c5 b takes c5
now now you're really just trying to
open up that bishop a little bit more
um so black plays the move queen e6 to
try to hold on to all the pawns
which is quite logical um
and here fabiano plays a move which i
believe
um like
a computer will say this move is a
mistake but i think most strong human
being players would play this move not
without thinking but would play this
move pretty easily
and the reason why is because they're
trying to free their pieces and to leave
the pieces like this just is so
unnatural
so he plays the ponzac c6 i feel like
any human player would just play this
move
uh if they see it because it's just you
gotta get your guys out you gotta do
something
but a computer we'll call this move a
mistake
the real question though is how should
you recapture this pawn if you're black
because you obviously wanna
take this pawn but you have four options
you could take with the bishop the pawn
the knight of the queen
and which option is the strongest option
and that is the question i am currently
posing
yeah rook b1 was probably a bit passive
um you're you have to deal with rook c3
type moves then as well because it hits
the knight and if you defend it the b3
nightwing
so
so take it with the queen stops knight
c5 i would argue that knight c5 okay
bishop takes then yeah knight c5 is
maybe his intention
and i would guess that black white gets
some counter play maybe you could even
think about taking out e7
first that's a tougher question but like
knight c5 and you get counter play for
sure right
so that's something although bishop
takes is probably not so horrible
queen takes is what was played in the
game but i don't think it was best if b
takes c6
i think like if knight c5 immediately i
take
and take here and this i think is good
for black
but i think the move that would worry me
after b takes
um what was it
because knight c5 i don't think works
but you had there was a good move here
i'm trying to recall now
um
maybe it's actually bishop takes a6
because the whole idea now is that now
knight c5 is actually kind of a thing
which you have to deal with so maybe you
could take this pawn i guess white could
take this
black could take this but maybe your
apon becomes problematic
even this looks pretty good for black to
be honest
but i feel like it's not the clearest
so queen dick c6 was played in the game
but again not the best i think there's
actually the best move is actually
knight takes e6
and the idea is that after bishop takes
f8 you have to take with the correct
piece if you take with the king then
knight c5 is embarrassing because knight
c6 is check so instead you should play
knight takes f8
but here knight c5 just doesn't work
because it loses the piece
and believe it or not i think white's
just a huge trouble because
i'm gonna take on d4 next and the two
connected pawns in the center are just
gonna roll
and it's one of those cases where being
up the exchange is not nearly
uh strong enough
that having those central pawns rolling
up the board is going to be much more
meaningful
and will probably just destroy uh
white's position here
because knight takes d4 is a huge threat
if you play queen b1 i take
knight takes d4 you have to defend your
bishop and now again
probably different ways but i think
maybe the simplest is even just to take
this guy and play d4
d4 you can't play queen c4 because your
knight hangs
c4 is coming next and i think this is
just going to be bad
so i think that knight takes e6 would
have actually been extremely strong for
nepo
and he like would have just won this
game as it happened
he played quite a c6 and now fabiano
plays bishop c5 which is a good move
keeping d4 nice and defended
rook c8 he unpins himself
and now bishop b5
knight c1 and this is excellent played
by fabiano because
he's not just he's like really fixing
his pieces because after bishop e292
you look at white's pieces and all of a
sudden they're actually quite good
like the knight on e3 and e2 the bishop
on c5
all of these pieces are actually quite
good here
so i think that this is
just a reasonable position almost like
we're actually getting a position which
is quite good
keep in mind also this is a must-win
game
so not only was he fighting for his life
he has to win this game in order to
survive
but we're not nearly done with the
the complications here so queen b3
and already we're getting to the point
where nippo has to be very careful
because fabiano's reorganizing his
pieces and this is something he does
remarkably well
once he knows where his pieces are
headed he's very good at maneuvering him
there in the correct order
so this position i actually think black
already has to be quite careful
um i really think he should pitch this
d5 pawn with knight c6 which looks like
an insane move
but the idea is that if knight takes d5
you can actually play knight takes a5
because knight e7 check and knight f6
check you just move the king
and you actually don't achieve very much
because your queen hangs
um so you could play them with queen a2
but then i could play queen f7
and kind of pin your own knight
so this would be actually quite
interesting
maybe he could try rook b1 instead
but now you can still play knight takes
the a5
and after queen a2 here
uh now there's knight c4 type stuff so
the queen a2 here is not as strong
so instead i think queen b6 was the move
um
the idea being you want to win the b7
pawn but knight c4 trading off the
strong e3 knight at least is kind of
unclear
because say you trade off this knight
and take here i would say this position
is probably
decent for white but it's also not like
super clear so
i don't know i feel like black's at
least in the game because you've traded
off the e3 knight which is quite quite
strong
alright so
queen to b3 and king h8
so kick h8 and now rook b1 and the
problem here is that king h8 looks like
kind of an auto move that you play just
to get out of the pin
but the drawback is now you're kind of
playing the same lens except you're a
tempo down
so here maybe he could give rook c7 a
try
it's strange but at the same time it's
kind of the kind of play you do when you
don't realize you have to be like that
careful
uh and they're easy moves to make kind
of an autopilot like gig h8 you could
make an autopilot but then you realize
things are tricky
so i actually think rook c7 might be the
best try the idea of being a bishop b6
you go back
but i think now white brings the knight
in and tries to take on d5
and here probably knight f8 to try to
play knight e6
but at least here you're just losing
your d5 pawn which is actually not the
bad pawn to lose
and again maybe black's kind of in the
game still
he plays knight c6 but now after queen
takes b7 he's lost this crucial b7 pawn
i think he has some problems
so knight takes a5 rook to d7
and this position i actually think is
really really bad
and the main reason is because he just
has numerous numerous weaknesses the d5
pawns the weakness the f5 pawns a
weakness
and i think that this position is
actually incredibly bad
um and it's amazing how quickly it
happened like keep in mind here
like rook c5 was like a fighting for his
life type of move
but all it takes is a few mistakes queen
takes c6 instead of knight
c6 which would have been very strong uh
later in the game not playing
knight c6 when he had to and it just
takes one little mistake after one
little mistake
fabiano playing like really really good
moves as white and it
now all of a sudden he just has a
problem
so this position after rook d7 i think
is actually quite bad
so nepal tries to play knight b3 which
is a fairly
reasonable approach trying to create
counter play
knight takes f5
and this position is already quite nasty
i think he should try taking this bishop
and then white probably should take on
g7 but at least here i felt like
there's some counter play there's some
chances but this was actually an
important moment so he plays bishop f6
white plays bishop d6 which i think is
incredibly strong and black plays a5
and now this end game is actually
remarkably complicated
and this moment in particular is a very
very important one
so i think that white has a very very
strong continuation here
but this is a moment where i think that
actually fabiano went a bit astray
so see if you guys could find some a
good move for white to play because i
think white actually has
an incredibly strong move here
yeah they plug you have to be careful of
so bishop b5 looks very tempting and
but you have to be very very careful of
this move
yeah i mean rook a7 is what was played
in the game and then h5 was played by
nippo
um and the game kind of continued uh but
i think that here
um white missed a a really promising
option well rook b7 i think you could
play a4 like i don't think you're
stopping the pod from running
um
g5 is not a legal move you can try g4 to
g5 that's kind of interesting
um i don't know if it's the clearest
option but it's definitely possible
rook b7 allows a4 i don't know if i
would allow that uh if i were black
bishop a3 is the wrong direction you're
you're trying to be aggressive here
hey darkhead
uh again not so clear i think it's very
slow and
and you give you've give black time
they're going to kind of play keep in
mind also that knight takes d4 is a
thing
g4 is interesting i kind of like g4 g5
um
but i don't think it wins immediately
like i still can
fight on um maybe that h4 type moves are
actually annoying sometimes
i'm not sure like rook d8 and if you
move the rook that h4 something like
that
yeah rook f7 is incredibly strong
so uh so bishop d8 it would be the
uh the move to save the bishop
but here white can win pretty easily so
why can't he play bishop d8
yeah rick of it or bishop e5 check uh
does the job knight takes e5 rook f8 uh
fk g8 then here so this actually wins
but your line does remind me of this so
i didn't look at this before but i just
saw it so after rook c2
you could actually play your line after
rook takes f6 takes e2
this is actually a beautiful way to mate
rook fade
check and mate this would be a beautiful
way to end the game no
i mean come on this is the way to end
the game
um so yeah rook f7 would have been
incredibly strong so
i mean black basically has to just pitch
the f6 bishop
but if you pitch the f6 bishop you're
going to lose right
um you could try a3 bishop rook takes
bishop and then try to do something
active but quite honestly you're not
getting anywhere
uh for example you could try this but
quite honestly like nothing is gonna
work here you could even play bishop a3
if you
just want to kill it
but yeah so rook f7 would have been a
really nice opportunity
instead he played rook a7 which is not
as accurate
and now nepal plays a good move in my
opinion at h5 i don't know objectively
like
again i really disregard computer here
because white's so crushing kind of
um but it's one of those things where
[Music]
h5 to me is a great human move because
you're giving your king luft you're
giving your gig a square
and it means that you have a better shot
but here once again white has a very
very strong move
that he could have played
yeah exactly angelos like it's easier
for us to see rook f7 it's still not
simple
but if he has time and if he knows
there's a move of course they're gonna
find it real fast these guys are strong
and much faster tactically than all of
us um
but at the same time if you're not
necessarily looking for it if you don't
realize there's something that powerful
it can be
quite tricky and it still is a very very
crushing position but you'll see soon
enough how if you don't
find the crushing blow soon enough
sometimes it disappears and then it's
not so easy
i don't know about that though i feel
like rick f7 you find eventually right
just because it's the most forcing move
but the question is what to do here
bishop c7 is possible although i do
think i can play bishop d8 there
uh and that might at least be somewhat
problematic like i still fight on
it truly is but then the thing is you
can still see them miss simpler things
that sometimes we would see so it kind
of makes you realize though like how
many dimensions there are to chest
strength because chest strength doesn't
mean
they're gonna see the things we miss
every time or that
it's we're incapable of seeing things
that
they can't they don't see it's more that
if we
if you know like the amount they see as
they play it's quite
difficult to fathom i would say um
but at the same time especially when
they're playing rapid and blitz they
make quite a few errors so
the games are kind of closer to what we
would think of as play like us playing
right
so
because again i mean obviously you know
i i'm you know
i'm a gm i can play a gm level but the
difference between maya level and these
guys is still
quite quite large um
like it's hard to to explain like how
big of a gap it it actually is
kick f2 d3 again is very slow i i don't
like it
you want to look for things that are
more aggressive first right
i don't know g4 gambiting that pawn i
feel like you have to get something very
clear for that
and by the way guys it's not an idea you
haven't seen so
i feel like you guys are looking for too
too subtle you know king f2d3
these are all nice improving moves but
there's look for your forcing
moves first right you guys are trying to
be a little bit too intricate
yeah rook f7 again is quite strong
actually because the bishop doesn't have
it has to move here and then you go here
and this knight just runs out of moves
because the bishop coming to e5 is going
to be crushing right
so this actually wins in the same way i
still like nippo's h5 move because
if you don't see rook f7 h5 is a good
try for a defense
um but sometimes you just have to allow
one move which wins and crushes you and
that's sometimes part of defense
you allow one move that crushes you but
not every move doesn't crush you right
and that's kind of the point so i didn't
mean to trick you guys but rook f7 it's
it's a similar idea right but it's the
same thing
so in the game however he played bishop
e5 and this i definitely don't like
because now
the game becomes incredibly messy and
remember i talked about before how maybe
one of nippo's issues with technique was
sometimes he gets a little lackadaisical
again by these guys standards not by
normal standards but
he sometimes will like he just played
king f2 and king g3
rather than the moves which were more
precise i would say fabiano sometimes on
the other side which is he
he doesn't fear complications at all he
believes in his calculating ability
and he tries to be very precise the
trouble the problem with this sometimes
is that you end up choosing lines which
are very very complicated for no reason
and this was a position where he had
something very very simple
only the bad ones that's funny
so he plays bishop takes e5 and here i
actually think that fabiano should take
with the f pawn
just to keep this deep five pun under
control and he gives the f4 square for
his knight
i think this would have been still quite
good for white he plays d takes e5 which
i think is really really risky to be
honest
so nipple plays rook c2 and now i think
the game is just a mess again
because knight d4 knight takes knight
takes
rook d2 knight f5
so it looks quite good for white in that
you have the like black's king on h8 is
quite bad you have these pawns the
knight on g6 is bad
but black also has lots of passers here
and after d4 i would at least be
marginally worried
so this position maybe even should be
drawn with best play
um so both guys are kind of playing
force moves so fabiano plays e6 there's
no real way to stop this pawn
so black plays e7 but the drawback here
is
these puns of blacks are also not so
easy to stop he plays e7
so he must capture it sacrifice the
knight rook takes e7
a4 but now the trouble
is how do you actually stop these puns
and how would you stop them
so here you guys have lots of decisions
to make to end this game so
so if you play net h4 here i think this
a pod is going to beat you to the punch
because now if you try check and here
this a pawns are ready to queen
if you go here um
so if i play rook b2 you might have a
point maybe f6 wins because
if check here queens
you get to finish with the beautiful
rook g7 mate the problem with this
is that i think i can stop you i can
play a move like rook f2 for example
and now your pawn's not moving and i'm
ready to play d3 d2 on you
so this actually looks problematic if
you try to play
net h4
i mean while pushing the pawn
oh a black knight is on g6 okay you're
talking way farther back yeah we're
already kind of here
um ah so like this position
that h4 here it's quite interesting um
the problem i think is i can play check
first and then i take your knight with
check
so you have to recapture and then i go
here you actually just lose i think
so it's a cool idea but i think this is
a problem
so knight h4 doesn't work so they will
for this and knight takes d4 is indeed
the move
knight takes e3 is a similar version the
problem is that after takes takes
i think that black can play rook to a2
and this rook on the second is just too
annoying i think a position like this
you're just not gonna win you could play
h3
but i'll play a3 for instance instance
excuse me
and i think this is just not going to be
winnable because you can do this
but now i simply bring my kick up and
there's just no way to make progress
your king can't really come up
and if you try to push your pawns i just
try to blockade the with the king if
your rook ever leaves the third i play
rook b2
a2 this kind of position is not really
going to be winning
so you're not going to win that way so
he takes d4 which is the best try
but i also think this position should be
drawn but this position actually here is
very very important
the question is what is the correct move
to play um
if you're black here
so if you play rook d5 then i think i'll
check
and i'll go here and once my rook gets
behind the pawn i think i have really
good winning chances
um not that it's a complete win just now
but i feel like this is gonna be pretty
good chances for
for white
to win so it's a little bit more
accurate to play the move rook d8 so the
rook can't go behind
and now i thought the best try was
rookie five
if you play rook a3 or something like
this and i play rook here i just don't
think you can win once again because i
bring the king up
and you just really can't make progress
in a position like this because if your
king goes over to the queen side
eventually i'm just gonna take your
pawns
and if you try to play h3 i actually
just kind of wait for you i do this
if g4 i take take king f6 and you just
don't really have a way to make progress
if king e4 i check you
and just move the rook back to a8 so
here what i'm talking about is something
like check
and i can even just keep checking you if
i want and come here and you're just way
too slow to try to win this way
um actually sorry i could probably do
this a bit more accurate so something
like check and then like rook here
the idea being that
um if you try to push the pawn i go here
and this is gonna be a dead draw
so this is one example um
and if you try to come in like this then
i push my pawn here
and by the time you can give a check but
the problem is now a2 a1 is a threat so
you have to come back
so you just can never win these kind of
positions usually
so that's why the best try is actually
rookie 5 because now you're actually
going to win three pawns
but the problem is after i play rook a8
you take on h5 king g7 and you come back
the problem here is that after king g6
g4
even though you get this i can't take on
f4 because if rook takes a2
but even this position you just can
never win because something like king
here king here
h4 and now i just start attacking
everything
so g5 check king of five you're not
going to win anything
um rook takes f4 is a threat already
so because you're just going to take the
f g pawns which is a dead draw so you
could try this but i just give a check
and i just go back and forth and you
just can't really do anything
so even though you have two extra pawns
because your rook is so passive just
sitting on a1
you can never really win so this is an
example of how the passive like the rook
the rook on a1 is just so bad when the
black looks behind
so this is just um
rook d8 would be a draw but keep in mind
when these guys have no time to discover
all this in the rook end game
to see all these subtleties is very
tough he plays h4 which seems good
and fabiano plays king g2 which also
seems logical but i think both these
moves are blunders after h4
i think that white if they play yay
check first
and then king g2 i think white should
probably win
because there's no real way to stop the
two versus one now so for example let's
say you play
check take this pawn for instance
and then a3 i simply go here
and now you could even bring your rook
behind or play a2
but this kind of position believe it or
not is actually quite easy to win even
with the pawn here
because the main issue is you can just
never make a threat
so here for example maybe i start by
cutting your king off
you could just sit right i bring my king
up
and now i just slowly push all my guys
right here
i'll go here f5
rook a7 g4 and i just slowly push
everything up the board
and you actually can't win wow like i
saw it all at once that's
i guess it's not surprising he knows
this stuff yeah and if you try to win
this way or sorry if you try to play
this way this is also not going to work
because i go here
and now for example king f5 and the key
is that after a2 i play g4
and you can't move your rook and attack
a pawn
so you just have to sit kind of but then
once this happens
you're just kind of toast because say if
something like king here
i can simply play this and here
and once again you just don't work
well here's the difference after king g2
nipple has the opportunity to play the
move rook d8 which he did
and now once again you're ready to get
the rook behind the pawn
which should draw and here fabiano
played the move g4
uh if rook a3 the key here is that black
can actually play the move rook d4
i think rook a4 might still because yeah
the problem here is that if you play
ah so probably takes is actually good
enough to draw as well something like
this would also be good enough
uh to draw come to think of it so this
would probably draw as well
uh for the same reasons that we kind of
saw before after this we go here
and we just kind of put the k got f5 and
this should also draw actually
so this would have been a draw so that's
why fabiano plays g4
and here nipple plays a very accurate
move he plays the move rook b8 so the
idea of this move is that he's ready to
kind of give checks and do this kind of
thing
and it prevents keg h3 because keegan h3
rook b3 you actually lose which is funny
so fabiano plays again a very clever
move he plays rookie 4 which is correct
and here nepo only has one drawing idea
so what is the drawing move for nipple
and he misses it
and it's amazing the subtleties and the
difference between what he got and what
would have been a draw
because it's actually amazingly
different
yes rooks belong behind past pawns
however he played the move rook a8 here
which is a blunder
the correct move is a3 and this would
have drawn
because for example if here king h3 now
you play rook a8
and if rookie 1 a2 king g7 and we have
the same idea we had before king takes
h4 king g6
and this position is actually not
winnable for the same reasons i showed
you
that at the kickoff's back i cut you off
and i'll play rook a4 rook a3 till the
end of time
and if you try to play something like f5
check and i go king f6 you just have no
way to make progress
because i'm ready to queen already so
this would have been a draw
after a3 rook a4 is what i assume was
the try
but now i could play rook b3 and this
rook on b3 is actually quite strong
the idea of rook b3 is that now if you
try to play f5 for instance
king g7 you actually have no way to win
because say g5
h3 check for instance king f7 and you
just can't win because
the second you try to do something like
let's say you play rook a7
king f8 g6 now i play rook b5
and if f6 i play rook f5 check
so you get a position where you just
have a past h pawn which is not nearly
enough this is a dead draw
so this whole thing with a3 would have
been a draw
but he plays rook a3 and now fabiano
plays rook e2
and this is the kishu point you stop the
pawn when it's on a3
and not on a2 and because he has this
extra tempo
it actually proves to be a quite an easy
win because once you do this
rook a4 king g3 there's no check along
the side
the third rank and because there's no
check along the third rank
white has all the time in the world to
advance these pawns
so it turns out this pawn being one
square farther back
causes the game instead of being a draw
to be a loss
and it's actually quite simple he just
keeps pushing like anyone could win this
position probably check
h5 check so if king here he would have
just played this move probably because
you can't take on f4 because i take here
and then kg5 or g5 check whichever gets
allowed
so he plays kick f6 but he plays kick h4
anyway
rook goes back to a8 f5 so now he's
going to try to play this
g5 he doesn't even care about getting
cut off which is really funny
because there's just no way to ever stop
these pawns now they're just too far
and the problem is because this pawn is
here
white can afford to go here at the last
minute so i'll show you what i mean he
plays king g8
g6 king h8 this looks silly but there's
just nothing he can do
king f3 kick here and the reason he
played king f3 by the way is because
after f6 which he'd love to play this
move i think he found problematic with
the idea that at f7 you have check
so we place king f3 to sidestep that
king to g8 f6
king h8 uh he fell in the overall match
he won this particular game but he fell
out in the
match and now is where he plays rookie
two and the whole idea is now he
threatens mate
so after rook a8 he plays f7 and the
game is over
so he resigned because rookie what's
really funny is this f7 move would be a
blunder
probably if this pawn weren't here
because then you could start checking
and just
like give away your rook anywhere so
it'd actually probably allow a draw
so it's actually quite funny that this
is uh
that this is uh the winning move
so you can see how because the pawn was
on a3 and not a2
uh he was able to win and this really
goes to show with these rook end games
how subtle they are
because the idea of putting the rook
behind the palm was absolutely correct
at first
but a few moves later it was actually a
blunder to put it behind the pawn
and he should have played a3 with the
idea of rook b3
the kid could go to f8 but rookie a
check is still a drawing move yeah
so i don't think it would matter but
yeah i mean obviously with the pawn on
a3 this is an easy one because rookie 8
is going to win
so fabian was won this game and tied the
match for yesterday
but today nepo was able to win the match
and go to the
semifinals so that was that but it was a
really dramatic match and a really
amazing game like with lots of mistakes
lots of different things but a lot of
cool things to analyze so it was a lot
of fun analyzing this game i hope you
guys enjoyed it
uh this will be my last lectures for the
club for a while uh
but i will do a couple more streams on
youtube one will be
saturday at 4 pm i'll be doing a simul
and then
sunday i have the the beginner's classes
or
and the intermediate classes at 1 pm to
3 p.m and then the puzzles paradise at
five
thank you davina and uh thanks everyone
i appreciate it
i hope you enjoyed it and uh i will see
you guys next time